dylan bundy and the angels and it's been
a tough year for him certainly his 13th
start of the year the team is four and
eight in dylan's first 12 starts yeah
but you can
move that all aside by having a very
good game this afternoon to complete a
four
sweep against the tigers jonathan scopes
had a nice series he's looking for more
of that that one hit hard out to random
on the ground that was a change-up
that again i mean he went 0-2 and he's
glad his defense is there but he went
0-2 and flirted with the the heart of
the plate three straight times yeah that
was a great defensive play that's a
tough one for anthony rendon his
baseball scolded at him he's got to be
able to field it really didn't get a
chance to backhand it
but still got himself a good throwing
position
450 slugging percentage on 02 counts
this year against dylan button that's
way too high for o2 especially with his
stuff
jamer candelario
that's a change up and it's popped up
random looks right into the sun as the
shades on perfect shades and he puts it
away one two three ready to face the 24
year old native of springville alabama
casey mize and there's one away 2-2
count
struck him out went upstairs with the
gas
and blew him away two outs that was
really a well executed pitch right there
you can almost sense that ohtani was not
going to take any of those fastballs in
so what does he do he goes up in the
zone
out of the zone and ohtani's in swing
mode brings up taylor ward for casey
mize into his motion to strike one swing
a little pop fly by first base miguel
will go into foul territory make a
basket catch two steps into foul
territory beyond the bag ward pops out
good first inning for casey myers and
the tigers we go to the second inning
scoreless tigers and angels dylan bundy
who has to work out of a bases loaded
situation here here's the next pitch he
swings it that one hits it on one hop
second for one relay to first it's a
double play
wow
that ball
almost hit the umpire at second base the
inning is over on a
fine double play turned in by the middle
of the infield for the angels now jamers
in a great hitters count two outs
he can be selective here
base hit scores the guy from second the
payoff
grounded to second
booted by fletcher candelario's safe
scope's gonna score on the play it's
one-nothing tigers
he never stopped great again heads up
base running there you wouldn't think
jonathan scope would be that guy but
second baseman kind of nonchalance this
after he boots the ball rare error on
the very sure-handed david fletcher
backed up on the ground ball onto the
outfield grass make it a little easier
playing it just took a hop he wasn't
expecting i think and hit him on the
heel of the glove tried to throw home
but by that time scope had already
crossed home plate here's wash out the
plate one ball two strikes to count
high fly ball happy father's day out of
here
boy he didn't foul that one off he
banged it out of the ballpark
and just like that one swing of the bat
ties up this game at 1.
jared walsh home run number 18 on the
season and i love what he said to trent
rush last night after the game when he
got that hanging breaking ball
trying to ask him what is your mindset
when you see that hanging breakable he
goes swing
and this one is another hanging slider
that's right down the middle of the
plate and boy does he swing
hits it into the seats in right field to
tie this game at one
we'll see what the tail of the tape is
on that one it was not a cheap home run
by any stretch another great opportunity
now for the tigers base is loaded again
and now miguel cabrera stands in
there's a ground ball through the left
side
an rbi single for miguel cabrera rogers
scores scope never stopped it's two runs
home for detroit and they're up 3-1 just
what they needed chip miggy just
sort of protecting that inside part of
the plate hits the ball on the ground
but it finds a home between short and
third and scope reacting very well to it
he immediately takes off
roger scores easily but scope on the run
left fielder taylor ward way off line
with his throw two big runs yeah big
moment and the big fella comes through
he chases
chris rodriguez tigers have reclaimed
the lead suarez has saved the bacon of
this team several times whether it's a
short start or in this case the
struggles of his relief mate here is daz
cameron with the bases loaded
fastball elevated strike three they're
back to let that one go 93 needed that
punch out gets him suarez suarez is set
facing mazara
fastball struck him out and that is how
the inning win back-to-back strikeouts
show hey oh tony and 50 names right back
in here tennessee tie with one swing in
the back and ohtani swings and drives
the ball deep into center field this
one's well hit it is out of here
he's done it again
oh tony has just did a two-run homer
he's homered in each of the last three
games of this series has four homers in
those three games and this fall game is
all tied up at three and sunday
is showtime
well we've seen cho hay hits the balls a
very long way this one scrapes the fence
in dead center field right over the top
of the
fence and slides out for that two run
shot for shohei ohtani home run number
23
by the way already a career high new
pitcher for the tigers as expected jose
cisneros he takes over gregory soto here
in the eighth taylor ward the 2-2
swung on him cisnero picks up right
where gregory soto left off runaway
tough day tough series for anthony
rendon
right back up the middle on the backhand
scope takes his time and throws him out
let him position perfectly rindon got
jammed a little bit the ball wasn't hit
quite as hard as it appeared but guess
who was standing right there jonathan
scott two away here's jared walsh the
2-2 swing in a pop-up foul
behind home roger's coming over and
he'll make the catch by the on deck
circle on the third base side another
good inning for a tigers reliever is his
narrow certainly don't want to walk the
lead off man you've got to attack it i
would think a fastball's in order here
see what he gives stassi here and he
struck him out at the knees
beautiful fastball i should say at 98 to
get stassi looking one away you know
you've got to throw a strike here
but then you make your pitchers pitch
right at the bottom of the zone good job
from jake rogers again
pulling that glove back up and
as you can see there that ball was right
there at the bottom
stassi didn't like it but that's
probably because he didn't feel like he
could hit it the 1-2
he got him on the corner
back-to-back strikeouts from jose
cisnero both of them looking
to away in the angels night one click
away from triple digits right there
cisnero has struck out three of the five
batters he faced and now here's juan
laguerrez
fly ball
shallow right center out go scope but he
makes a nice grab
the angels are retired one two three on
11 pitches from jose cisnero infield in
tight bases loaded nobody out 10th
inning 3-3 game the 1-2
up the middle and a base hit for dez
cameron candelario scores willy castro
trots home clutch hit by daz cameron
here in the 10th on a 1-2 count happy
father's day to mike cameron and the
tigers have a two-run lead the go-ahead
run steps to the plate in the form of
taylor ward as a pitcher this is all
about
you and the pitter with two outs the o2
he got him swinging great job michael
fulmer strikes out the side in the 10th
and the tigers leave anaheim with a 5-3
win